I always say I'm not going to do it this time.
I'm not. I don't need it. We're not we're not going to do it
Well, then here we are, at it again.
Does not approve.
It's not a flattering or best angle,
but it's all I've got to work with.
because there's no time to waste we must,
Use haste.
How many times have I walked down these steps and said, "Hey guys, we're off to the Apple store."
There was a time once when I said, I will never be first in line for an apple product
And then that all changed.
I promise you that I will never be the first person in line for any sort of Apple event.
There is no way.
BeeP BooP
You see where all your crazy?
Friends with you this morning. I really only asked Jenna to sit with me
I don't [think] all the coffee in the world could have convinced her to come here today. And technically I'm only really waiting for an hour
This is just silly
I think they're power washing the uhh the street now so i'm gonna have to probably move
Oh now my seat is wet but i will just sit in it anyways
I got some times to kill so usually the Apple store opens 10 o'clock
I had high hopes that couldn't open at eight usually for new [Zones] the product launches. They do open early
I may be waiting outside in front of the apple store the order and iphone on my eyes
We can never said I'm crowded
The thing is if I'm able to get a burger that I'll [just] go home and come back and see that my preorder in fact
At this point. I might poultice it yet what else
Attempted here right now
51 degrees right now still Exert all the people that I thought we're waiting in line. It was like. Oh cool
There's some other people here
They worked here and they were waiting to get into the store because they were going to work ditto on today
No, one nothing's happening like can you believe this?
Alright, well, they're preparing my order still though. You know we wasn't ready to pick up, so I'm gonna go home
Great Apple throw see you later
First in line for Red iphone don't Forget it. I might have went home, but I got in mind
Just the pre-order just in case I didn't get one
Why we for what you no confirmation that says justine your her that I phone is ready
I'm setting up to shoot the unboxing [okay] to worry
I'm not offer of course the battery's dead
These batteries not so quick in the cameras it's crazy
Let's got a studio minima office, and I shout him okay. That's good. I like
That's what I like when you think about this gina. What this is Mandy
Look at what I'm going to be wearing bye dear for you to rewind they sent out
really awesome
Jackets for everybody that was in it. I've been reading to make a video about this for quite some time, but I never did
Didn't man little man. You remember the me today would you like?
Visible with me. Do you like it?
That's what you like
and Canada
I'm sure I need a usb cable. I just got the extra La nuit that my phone is ready for pickup
It's a story that we care. What kinds it. It's nine thirty eight. How many times if I walk down these steps instead?
Hey guys, who is the Apple cart?
Here we are
I think I need to get the white piece also my other one I
should fall
we're
Talking other phones dances and you want to came out?
It's a new color is called Barry absolutely well down the floor yet there right now searching downstairs trying design is mostly
Hopefully, we'll have a suitable the other way
pick you up
Hello, hey, what do you guys think of this red iphone?
harness yet, do you think
Look fuzzy. Sorry my little finger Lucky. Well. I have a red phone. I like it. I like it a lot
Oh, it's nice, but wait, but I'm confused because but when I have a regular, too
He's made mommy well. This is [the] red Red phone and this was nukka when you look at that
What color like what type of thing do you can't immediately think about a fruit oh?
Cherry oh you have a fine. He only a simple Berry. What about like I liked cherry
I always get so many compliments on my red case which I'm like
It's a basic red case what I would have made the same color is the case well
I really missed you at the apple store today when I went and
Camped out for no reason at all if I would [have] showed up at 7am to camp out with you
I mean, but to be Fair I
Was afraid that I wouldn't be able to get a pre-order, and then I'd have to camp out anyway
So whatever we got the phone. I'm still debating what I want to do with [it]
do I want to keep it do I not I haven't transferred over any of my stuff yet because I'm
Fearing a little skeptical, but I'm not sure it's one of those things where it looks incredible without a case, but for me
I gotta have a camera. I just don't like the way my face
Did you guys haven't checked out the unboxing feel free to go check it out?
And this is many many hours wow wow the puker was that with some toy aggression
I also have some other red accessories Apple watch band a really cool iphone charger and medical stuff so check it out
I'll see you guys later. I'm going to go and I'm going to actually be editing this video right now, so right
Yeah, right. Now. We got a phone guys. I'll go through all the red goodies to
This is not a part of that
Either this is One my favorite Vlogging tripod
Incredible not a part of this unboxing things going to be cutting out today. We've got the red Apple watch band. We've got